so I've been traveling through time from
the 1820s to 1990 we've been searching
through history to find out where our
technology came from in that time we've
seen war social change and uncertain
times that sparked revolutionary ideas
that change the world as we know it how
did we get where we are today and what's
in store for the future what kind of
things do we have to look forward to in
this program we'll keep moving and we'll
find the answer
continuing on in our journey we find
ourselves at the start of what some call
the last great decade the 1990s
here we'll begin to see the world shrink
rapidly as we enter the Information Age
sharing whatever information we want
instantly but wait even this was amazing
in the 90s the whole world was connected
for the very first time but how did it
happen there's no doubt that the one
driving force behind the world getting
smaller was the public emergence of the
Internet the story of the Internet
itself is quite long and complicated and
will not fit the format or the nature of
this program so we're only going to
really touch on the basic key points the
story does end up being quite
fascinating though just think about the
story the next time you're browsing the
Internet it all started in 1957 when the
Russians launched the Sputnik satellite
much like the first man in space and the
initial acceptance of the integrated
circuit it was once again the Russians
that indirectly started a technological
revolution much like the rest of the
United States President Eisenhower went
into a panic and commissioned the
Advanced Research Projects Agency or
ARPA to compete with the Russians the
Americans needed an indestructible
communications network that would stay
up and running even though part of the
network was destroyed by a Soviet attack
how could this be done well the answer
came from a ridiculously unexpected
source a mouse a mouse in a maze to be
exact an R per employee Paul Baran
looked at the way a mouse moved through
a maze and decided to model its behavior
as the basis of the new information
network and said well if we could model
a mouse going through a maze then we
should be able to do the same with
information it's still just incredible
to think that the very early ideas of
the internet came from a mouse the mouse
in a maze idea was refined and developed
further on throughout the 60s
in 1968 ARPA was finally ready to
connect some computers together and
start the network a few members of the
ARPA team went to contact some telephone
companies to get the project off the
ground
but the telephone companies couldn't
understand or see the use of connecting
computers together in a network they
didn't see that it was very important
for mainstream and after all
communications whether we've got we've
got our own communication systems here
at IBM AT&T does the telephone system
and what else do we need what's your
problem
so opera ended up finishing up the job
themselves with the help of some small
firms in 1969 while everyone was
focusing on man landing on the moon an
extremely important event happened floor
computers were linked up together and
the ARPANET was born just have a wild
guess as to what the ARPANET later
became the amazing thing was nobody
really owned it it had an open nature
which meant that anyone could make
changes and make comments on it and this
was key we still hold this key idea and
value today in ARPANET descendent the
Internet
in 1971 there were 18 computers on the
ARPANET network and by 1972 networks
began to spring up all around the
Western world but there was a problem
each and every single one of those
networks spoke a different language so
they couldn't interconnect and
understand each other this meant that
they were technically hundreds of
different internets and this wasn't much
use
so in 1983 this problem was finally
solved with the introduction of a
universal protocol and since that year
the world has just had one internet and
now were all connected as revolutionary
as an endless supply of newfound
information was it was largely
impractical because everything was
extremely hard to find to even be able
to use the internet you needed to be
fluid in text commands and a literal
computer expert enter Tim berners-lee
this guy invented something that we use
each and every day probably more than
most other things without even thinking
about it he invented the world wide web
basically he created the web page and
also pioneered the idea of clicking on a
link and getting from one place to
another so on the 6th of August 1991 he
gave out his invention free to the world
so it would grow and grow it did
the internet was still mostly private
though but in 1992 it became public back
then there are only 50 websites and most
of the internet was still text-based and
it was hard to use let me show you what
I mean this is how the internet works
before web browsers this will blow your
mind what's the big deal about Internet
why is everybody making such a fuss
about it why is it better than
CompuServe or prodigy or sever well the
chief benefit is that it's not owned by
one company or even a conglomerate of
companies like prodigy our country sir
if you're influenced by what those
companies thought your users would want
to do we're on the internet anyone can
put any service on and have it do
anything they want with it
at any kind of user control right it
states completely molded by the people
who all right let's take a look and show
me some of the neat things you can do on
the Internet ok the first thing we'll be
doing is looking for a job of friend of
a friend of mine who had just got our
teacher certificate and she's in the
Northeast so we'll be using a tool
called gofer which lets you burrow
around the internet and pop up where the
information you need happens to be and
we're going into the Online Career
Center and this will let you search the
job listings that also you let you
search resumes if you're looking for
people to work for you and here we'll
search for the word teacher it'll go and
perform the search so you're looking for
a teacher's job in the northeast here
we've got a small list of positions and
let's say she wants to be a substitute
teacher at the Bayview Healthcare Center
we'll get the list of contact
information the phone number the
requirements salary that kind of thing
it's pretty neat in itself oldest
changed in 1993 when the first proper
web browser was released it was called
mosaic but its name was later changed to
Netscape mosaic is one of those new
developments
it's a hypertext interface that lets you
browse any information service provided
by the internet mosaic was developed by
the National Center for supercomputing
applications with ARPA support the thing
that makes mosaic special is that it
gives everyone access without there
having to be
a rocket scientist they don't have to be
trained at because it's a
point-and-click interface and that
point-and-click instead of going through
information that's on your personal
computer it's as if there's a million
computers on the internet inside your
own personal computer these top level
researchers hope mosaic lures more
average computer users to the Internet
for the very first time people could
scroll view pictures and text and click
two links and go to other web pages
instantly it sounds ridiculously simple
now but back then it was a revolution
and it changed the world no one had ever
seen anything like it we had entered the
information age and there was no turning
back and with that let's move on but
quickly before we do let's take a look
at something quite fascinating this is a
1993 take of Internet Society you'll
quickly be able to see that the
attitudes of people back then were
completely different to what they are
now on the Internet I mean there's not a
lot of cursing or swearing there's not a
lot of personal cuts there's not a lot
of put downs that one would expect to
find there's not you know there's not
screen Falls of you know go to hell oh
I'm just surprising so the kind of
liberation is it is is mixed it's
interesting because one would think if
you're anonymous you'd do anything you
want and that kind of view is almost
laughable now it's completely the
opposite today ok so moving on by the
mid to late 1990s there was a whole lot
of information and it needed to be
organized desperately though internet
search engines around but they all
didn't really perform and left many
users frustrated it took two Stanford
PhD dropouts to change all of that
their names were Larry Page and Sergey
Brin like the changes that happen to the
personal computer in the 70s these two
guys would single-handedly start a
revolution that would change the world
at breakneck speed this time in 1996
they brought all the world's information
closer together with a thing called
backrub
or as we know it today Google
Google was officially launched in 1998
back then it was just a search engine
but as we know today it's a lot more
than just that well how big exactly is
Google what would happen if all of
Google's services
suddenly disappeared all at once well
this exact scenario happened on the 17th
of August 2013 and these were the
results this is amazing on this day an
unprecedented outage happened Google
search Gmail YouTube Google Drive and
most of Google's services had a blackout
for just two minutes and in that short
time 40% of the world's Internet traffic
disappeared Google is even bigger than
we think
pretty thought-provoking stuff but we've
got to keep going let's move on to the
2000s
looking at the state of the world at the
beginning of the 2000s and then looking
back again at the end of the 2000s it
was like a different planet anyway in
2000 Alfa was still doing pretty badly
and they needed something to pick
themselves up Steve Jobs had been
reelected as CEO and had been back at
the helm of the company since 1997 he
was looking to enter the largely
untapped market of digital portable
music it had been done before by other
companies but never well he needed an
outstanding idea that could not fail
this was apples last chance it's a long
story but it actually turns out that the
original brainchild for the iPod design
and even iTunes way of music
distribution can be traced back to the
1979 invention of the digital audio
player by British inventor Ken Kramer
the iPod really came at the right time
it's actually said that Apple's board
members were actually considering
shutting down the company closing doors
and selling Apple but how did the iPod
become so intensely popular one area was
its ease of use and navigation back in
2001 with most mp3 players he had to
manually click to each song and if he
had a thousand songs well forget about
it but the scroll wheel changed all of
that
the second reason to why the iPod was so
popular the headphones
nobody was selling mp3 players CD
players or Walkmans with white
headphones so each and every time a
person walked down the street with these
crazy white headphones that stood out
from everything else other people just
had to ask what is that and that
curiosity helped feel the hype for the
iPod it was so successful that it went
on to become one of the most culturally
recognized items of the decade when
Apple finally acknowledged that Cain
Kramer was the original brainchild they
gave him a free iPod it stopped working
eight months later the iPod took over
the world and brought Apple back into
the limelight for the first time in over
a decade the music industry had been
conquered the next target the mobile
phone
do you remember Nokia of course you do
it wasn't long ago that no Keogh was
like the Nike coke Mercedes or BMW of
the mobile phone industry this was
pretty much the way it always was
but on September 2nd 2013 Microsoft
bought Nokia for less than eight billion
dollars that's right Nokia as a mobile
company does not exist anymore
the huge billion-dollar companies of
yesteryear certainly aren't what they
used to be but how did this happen in
2007 the world was looking for a brand
new approach to the mobile phone the
start of the answer just needed a
company to be at the right place at the
right time with the right product I
think we're going to hit a grand slam
with this the new must-have device that
takes the iPod even further no buttons
on the front you'll notice that's a key
differentiator all touchscreen gadget
fans we want one but will it ever reach
a wider market hundred dollars fully
subsidized with a plan I said that is
the most expensive phone in the world
and it doesn't have built business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard whether you love the iPhone or
you hate it there's no denying that back
then in 2007 when the iPhone was
launched it showed a sign of the way
things have work from then on even
though people hated the way Steve Jobs
ran his company people just had to hand
it to him that this old touchscreen
slate phone was an interesting enough
device even though it cost six hundred
dollars on a two-year contract for the
eight gigabyte model but is really some
good marketing and some little fine
details that really made the iPhone sell
like hotcakes magic comes when you use
your finger on that thing you scroll
lists light by flicking like this it's
like a roulette wheel top like that it's
just so cool if it wasn't for the
breakthrough of the App Store the iPhone
could have just been one of those
devices which just looked cool and was
cool to use but just didn't catch on the
App Store made all the difference
what Apple marketed was that there were
web apps what would happen is you'd open
Safari and you would go to a website
that was designed for iPhone and you
could have HTML based games and
calendars and applications obviously
this didn't roll over well because Apple
announced the App Store but for the
first year there was no App Store it's
amazing how many people actually forget
for one entire year after the iPhones
launch it could run a grand total of 16
apps that's right there's only that one
home screen of apps and that was it and
this wasn't to mention how limited the
iPhone was compared to some other
devices out there no MMS no video camera
no cut and paste the list goes on Nokia
or Nokia blackberry and the rest of the
established phone companies have been
doing that kind of thing for years just
to give you an idea of how basic the
iPhones functionalities were back then
jailbreaking your iPhone only got you
custom ringtones and that's it of course
this ceased to be the case after the
release of the App Store in 2008 for the
first time a device was a blank canvas
and the software creators could make the
device be whatever they wanted it to be
due to the iPods huge success there was
a huge number of new-generation Apple
fans and they just went crazy for this
new iPhone and of course that meant a
big market which meant that everyone
wanted to write software and apps for
for the first time in almost two decades
people were writing software for a brand
new platform their creativity was only
limited by the hardware and as we all
know the rest is history
today billions of apps have been sold
and the mobile app space is pretty much
a new industry companies like Nokia
blackberry and Palm thought they knew
the game but they just couldn't see it
they couldn't visualize the future at
all they thought things would never
change
and before they realized it was too late
to prosper in the brave new world of the
new mobile industry a new way of
thinking was needed and one company that
possessed that attribute Google
midway through the iPod storm the
beginnings of something earth-shattering
was brought into the world in 2003 Andy
Rubin and rich Mena founded a company in
Palo Alto California named Android
incorporated Android will play a major
role in the late 2000s the next few
years became a blur as the modern world
as we know today began to form just like
the battle between the Macintosh and the
PC in the mid to late 80s the game was
once again hot this time the tussle was
between the iPhones iOS and the Google
Android operating system in 2008 the
first Android phone had arrived it was
the g1 the g1 was the product of the
joint effort between Google and HTC
it wasn't bad for a first try but as
expected there was a lot of room for
improvement the iPhone could basically
run circles around the g1 in terms of
speed ease of use and code efficiency
but Android had something up his sleeve
Android was open-source and fully
customizable this was key as it meant
that any individual or company could use
Android and tailor it to their liking
this proved to be very effective and
soon they'll Android phones from Samsung
LG Sony Ericsson which later became
saying and many more this ended up
presenting a major challenge to the
iPhone as the customer had much more
choice with Android instead of being
locked down with a closed operating
system however in the early days Android
phones were notorious for lag and from
an outsider's point of view the iPhone
was seen to be vastly superior due to
its smooth operation this was the case
up until 2012 when Android version 4.1
jelly bean was released this release saw
a drastic change in the underlying code
to not bore you with the details
basically it was more efficient so much
so that the phones ran smoothly at 60
frames per second although that
performance is arguable there was
definitely an improvement in the phone's
performance and since then Android
phones have been seen as a real serious
contender to the iPhone by everyone and
not just Android users by late 2000s we
began to see something pretty
interesting the phone and operating
system that you chose became an
indication of your personality iPhone
users were seen a particular way and
Android users were seen a particular way
the humble phone had become so much more
than just a device but why our phones
have become incredibly personal devices
that were all about us not only had our
smartphones become a gateway to all the
world's information but for the first
time in history we were in direct
contact with anyone in the world from
our pockets let's take a careful look at
how this happened
say she
one of the pivotal parts that will
become a major aspect of the world as we
know it was the social networking boom
what many people don't know is that
social networking can actually be traced
back to the mid 90s with sites such as
NGO cities and the globe not even to
mention that the internet before web
browsing was mostly used for socializing
with people around the world in forums
but regardless of what the technical
roots may have been it all really
started in 2002 with Friendster this
site was hugely popular in the Asian
geographical region with over 115
million users it showed the potential
for social networking in 2003 a group of
people at a university saw this and the
decision was made to build a social
networking site of their own that took
strictly the best aspects of Friendster
and within 10 days myspace was born by
2006 myspace had overtaken Google in
daily site visits the social media boom
had begun but the torch was about to be
carried onto something else
well that was the advent of Facebook
mean um it's obviously not nearly as
popular right now as MySpace's but it is
picking up a little bit of steam how do
you guys deal with that yeah I think
Facebook is is quite different you know
it's mostly people talking to each other
that know each other and MySpace has
always been more open Facebook founded
in 2004 at Harvard University by Mark
Zuckerberg and a few of his roommates
Facebook was the fuse that they led and
the explosion was bigger than they could
ever imagine today there are over 1
billion Facebook accounts and at last
count there was over 180,000 terabytes
of information the pot in the hills of
Facebook was the SMS of the internet
Twitter created by Jack Dorsey in 2006
Twitter has over 500 million users with
over 340 million tweets per day with the
advent of Twitter it really started
being about the here and now we began to
have a kind of second life an online
personal you
but this time you are no longer
anonymous the true familiar online
culture of today had arrived by the
mid-2000s but it was pretty weak there
was something missing
a way for anyone to broadcast themselves
their thoughts ideas and creations much
like a TV station or a channel if you
will of course this was YouTube without
YouTube this program itself would not
exist it happened in January of 2005 it
was up in my place in the city in San
Francisco and we were having a dinner
party and people had our digital cameras
there and we were taking normal digital
photos as well as movies there but when
we tried to share the movies and we
tried to email it back but he just kept
getting rejected bounced back we try to
upload and you know we sort of took a
look at with all the digital cameras now
with phones being able to take take
movies but this was going to be more and
more of a problem for other people and
we try to make and simplify this process
to make it as easy as possible to share
these videos online YouTube was founded
by Chad Hurley Steve Chen and jawed
Karim in 2005 all three were ex PayPal
employees just a mere one year later
YouTube was bought by Google with one
hour of video being uploaded every
second each EEB is huge millionaires
have been made from YouTube and YouTube
has made people famous as we begin to
see more and more class-a content from
YouTube it shows that the Internet is no
longer just for amateurs but the place
to look for future trends and future
Talent and now that everyone has a
camera in their pocket even
breaking-news can appear from YouTube
YouTube really was a revolution in the
way people consume their media social
media and portable devices have proved
to be the ultimate combination so by now
all of the technology needed to make our
modern lives possible has now fallen
into place as we move through time to
the 2010 s the decade where the future
meets today we begin to see a few things
firstly smartphones become incredibly
powerful at a rate which many find hard
to keep up with we see 64-bit mobile
operating systems emerge
Intel stepping into the market bringing
x86 processors with them we see glimpses
of the very distant future one example
of which is the convergence between the
smartphone and the PC picture this in
five years time if your smartphone was
as powerful as your PC is today running
PC software what would that mean for the
industry and what would that mean for
you so now you're finally seen where our
technology has come from but
unfortunately we're out of time so come
back next time to see the breaking
technologies of today and some amazing
ideas that really have potential to
change our future you've been watching
ColdFusion TV and as usual don't forget
to rate comment subscribe and share
thanks for watching guys peace and
that's the end of episode 2 thanks for
watching all the way guys this project
is pretty tough just for one guy doing
everything it's spinning a lot more work
than I would have expected that I'm glad
the second episode is done and hopefully
you guys learned something if you're new
here and wondering what this channel is
all about a good place to start would be
the ColdFusion TV links in the
description below
enjoy